this is your first album am I correct
yeah yeah so you've already sold over a
million albums right that's quite an
accomplishment don't you think yeah yeah
I mean did you expect that of course not
no I won't know I mean it's an
accomplishment just to make a CD how did
you get discovered I mean like because
you know that's pretty cool at 19 to
have a band and a recording that's
totally weird you don't even know about
this island I made all these demo tapes
and you know how you're supposed to make
like you know I guess you're supposed to
make like hundreds of them and send them
out right and I made like you know 100
up and then
I didn't even I never even handed one
out and everyone so I went out I gave
one to my friend and she was babysitting
for this woman who's in the business and
this woman had a party and Andy Slater
who's my manager and producer went to
the party and then he just called me and
met me and got me signed oh no kidding
so I never there's an interesting I
haven't even made an effort wow that's
really cool it's cool but yeah but
that's the thing it's like I never had a
chance to kind of like have a second
thought about it so sometimes I thought
wow maybe it happened like before I
could even decide no you didn't oh don't
worry don't worry about it don't analyze
it are you kidding me no don't not
analyze yeah but don't therapy now
you're gonna make yourself wrong because
it was easy yeah so what happens like
when you're 19 is like when you were
like 14 were you telling everyone you
wanted to be a rock star I don't know
really you know it's like it's sacred to
me I didn't want to be you know when
you're 12 years old and you're writing
songs that mean a lot to you and you go
and you tell people that you're writing
songs they think that you're like some
Little Debbie Gibson thing right right
and I was really not willing to have to
I don't like have to prove myself to
people you know right I'd be like no I'm
not stupid they're nice songs and
everything so I just didn't tell anybody
you know you know how like when you're
up there singing and stuff did you
practice your moves in front of the
mirror like guys do no and that's the
thing that's the thing about like how
everything happened so fast for me and
everything like it's a big break on one
hand but then again it's a big kick in
the ass because it's like you know I had
to develop my stage presence it's in
front of everybody it's not like I had
you know it's lucky for me that I didn't
have to like play in clubs for nine
years waiting for some Anar guy to come
but it's also unlucky because then I had
to like do it in front of a million
people that's what I was thinking you
know you're pretty good on stage you're
pretty poised you know I had to get up
there at 19. I'd probably be doing a lot
of good you still got boys let me tell
you I'd be doing like I'd be doing
Robert Plant stuff I'd be like oh
you want to know something people make
fun of that when I went up I did this
song with Rob Zombie on MTV I swear to
God I didn't know what to do because Rob
is jumping up and down like a maniac and
he's got all these stage moves worked
out Rob is really cool on stage I mean
he comes he first of all he was dressed
as a zombie and he's jumping up and down
the stage but he looked good like he
knew what he was doing yeah we would
make an ass of myself on stage so much
really so much when you try to do
something yeah like fans will give me
necklaces this fan gave me a long
necklace and I wore it and then I
started like trying to like head bang
and look cool and everything I hit
myself in the head
see that's when you run into trouble and
I like tried to step on a monitor and I
knocked the monitor over and like fell
down on the stage yeah like I think
that's cool you know people fall down
all the time yeah it's like what's a big
deal I'd get up and I say okay so it is
difficult to all of a sudden get on
stage and have a hit record and then
they say well get on stage and you've
never done it before right yeah like in
high school you never got up and started
performing dude no I never performed
with I never said anything even the
singing I mean did you stand in your
room and no and that's the thing and I
didn't even like when I went and I
brought my tape into Andy and everything
he said the first thing he said to me
was well you have a beautiful voice
first of all and I mean I looked at my
father like I I was so in shock because
my like my family they sing my mom and
my sister sing but they both have like
really kind of operatic kind of voices
yeah and if you grew up with a voice
like mine and you're listening to these
like whoa you know yeah you're gonna
feel like your voice isn't you know
you've got like a deep husky kind of
Soulful voice yeah kind of and then you
went out on stage the first time first
time in Paris in front of like 800 media
people and Sony Executives it was like
this big Sony Road show the Fugees were
there yeah um and they're real good on
stage yeah yeah everybody well everybody
had been on stage like a million times
I'd never been on stage at all I went up
there I had to do like 15 minutes and I
just didn't I didn't say a word to the
audience because like I can't do that
crap like hello Paris yeah right right I
can't I cannot bring myself to do that
yeah but you're shy I'm not shy you're
not no what is it why can't you say
hello Paris because it just seems
Showbiz yeah yeah it doesn't seem like
you yeah I'm not shy that's everybody
always thinks that I'm shy I just like
everybody talks when they have nothing
to say
foreign